we are days away from the strip
reopening and hotels are making big
changes
to make sure guests and employees are
safe eight news now reporter joe moeller
got a tour of the bellagio hotel and
casino today
and he shows us what to expect you'll be
able to notice the changes right when
you walk through the front door there's
now plexiglas at the check-in desk
another big change you'll notice are
these signs for mobile check-in
you'll now be able to check in for your
room straight on your phone
the phone will then be used to open the
door guests will have their temperature
taken right when they walk through the
front doors as well
as far as capacity the hotel will cap
out at 30 percent
and the casino floor will be at 50
percent the casino looks different as
well
tables will have dividers there will be
limited seating and there are new hand
washing stations
all of our employees are required to
wear a mask to something we put in place
back in april
we're testing our employees they're
going through thermal screening before
they show up they're going through the
cdc recommended questions and screening
protocols too um but also
we're asking our guests to do the same
thing the restaurants will have a lot
less contact
as well you will check in for the wait
list and view the menu from your mobile
device
here in the conservatory there are
markers here to maintain that social
distance of course
the bellagio will open at 10 o'clock on
thursday mgm and new york new york will
open 11.
reporting at bellagio joe moore 8 news
now